so the FBI investigation into Brett
Kavanaugh is happening I should say
another investigation the man has been
investigated by the FBI through FBI
background checks like like six times so
this is this is the seventh time the
seventh investigation no allegation or
hint of sexual misconduct was uncovered
through through the first six
investigations so now we're gonna have
we're gonna have a seventh one and and
maybe they'll turn something up this
time around now I've heard some very
frankly well stupid Republicans and
conservatives who have said hey you know
there's there's no problem here there's
there's no problem with a with an FBI
investigation what's the big deal with
an FBI investigation right it only it's
only gonna last a week and it'll help us
get to the truth so it's it's it's great
you know you don't you don't lose
anything here well to the people in that
camp I you really need to wake up from
your coma you you really it's it's I
think it's time that's it's a time to to
awaken and look around and just exist
within reality I think it's really time
for you to do that if you're in that
camp you need to realize that the
nothing the Democrats say is true
they're the ones who want this FBI
investigation nothing they say is true
nothing they say is set in good faith
nothing nothing at all there's a reason
why Democrats desperately want this
investigation and like everything else
that they say and they do it's got
nothing to do with the truth whatsoever
ever okay if Democrats were interested
in truth they wouldn't have held on to
these allegations until the last minute
if Democrats were interested in the
truth they wouldn't be entertaining wild
conspiracy theories they wouldn't they
wouldn't be entertaining these wild
stories from emotionally unbalanced
women
about roving high school rape gangs okay
if Democrats were interested in the
truth they wouldn't have announced that
they believed Christine Ford before the
before they'd ever even heard either one
of them testify if Democrats were
interested in the truth they would have
taken the opportunity during the hearing
to ask Christine Ford some actual
questions about what allegedly happened
rather than just taking turns giving her
high-fives and each other high-fives if
Democrats were interested in the truth
they would have actually asked Cavanaugh
about the allegations rather than asking
him about things that were in his
yearbook when he was 17 but Democrats
are not interested in the truth at all
whatsoever
in fact they've already said that
Cavanaugh is unfit for the Supreme Court
no matter what the FBI investigation
turns out they made they made that
declaration minutes after his nomination
was announced they'd already decided
that he was unfit and they made it on
the at the hearing on Thursday before
the guy to even testify they had
convicted him they've already said that
they that they believe the accuser they
don't need any more information and even
now as they demand an FBI investigation
they've already made it abundantly clear
that they're going to oppose him no
matter what and they're going to be
unsatisfied with the investigation no
matter what
but the investigation won't turn up
everything anything at all as as we're
all well aware if we've been paying
attention
because there's no evidence okay there
are no witnesses the accuser doesn't
even know the year or the place that
this attack allegedly happened so they
have nothing to go on they have nothing
to investigate we talked about FBI
investigation an FBI investigation has
to be investigating something what are
they going to investigate the only thing
they can do is is is is get the people
who are allegedly involved or allegedly
present and ask
about it well all of them have already
been asked and they've already put their
answers down on paper and writing on the
record under penalty of felony and
they've and they've all said that it
didn't occur so what else are they gonna
say it's not as though these people have
have said that yeah the thing happened
but it didn't happen exactly as
Christine Ford said it happened well if
that was the case then there would be
something to talk about but what they're
saying is this didn't happen there was
this event didn't happen or if it did I
have no memory of it whatsoever
Christine Ford's best friend in high
school sang I didn't even know this guy
well I wasn't at this thing so what
she's gonna what is she gonna say to the
FBI but is she gonna say it again in
Greek in Spanish what does she need to
do does she need to communicate it via
sign language or carrier pigeon or Morse
code that you need to draw a picture of
it not happening does she need to sing
it like an opera I mean what else can
she do what else can any of them do Ford
says that a certain party happened 35
years ago and a certain thing happened
at that party everyone else concerned
everyone else concerned says that no
such party happened okay and the only
person who claims the party happened
can't tell you when or where it happened
so how can you investigate that it's
it's like if I it's like if I called up
the FBI and I said hey FBI I need you to
investigate a terrorist threat okay I
need you to investigate and they said
okay who made the threat
I don't know when was the threat made I
don't know well what was the threat
exactly I don't know where was the
threat made I don't know what was the
threat against what do wonder that
what's the terrorists gonna attack I
don't know well what I don't know I
don't know it's just there was a threat
okay I mean there was a threat I
remember the threat and I remember how I
feel when I heard the threat is very
scared so so so please investigate no
the FBI wouldn't investigate that
because there's nothing to investigate
that's not even there's nothing for them
to go on for me to say that a terrorist
threat was made by someone somewhere at
some point is not enough and by the way
in that analogy at least a terrorist
threat is the kind of thing that the FBI
might investigate on the other hand
groping allegations between high
schoolers 35 years ago in the early 80s
is not the kind of thing that a federal
law enforcement agency investigates
because it's not a federal crime so the
investigation will accomplish nothing of
substance lead nowhere so why are the
Democrats so intent on it well there are
three reasons why their intent on it
okay and again it's got nothing to do
with the truth number one they want to
delay Cavanaugh's confirmation so that
they have more time to dig up dirt about
him number two they want to delay
Cavanaugh's confirmation so they have
more time to put pressure on the
cowardly squishy Republicans like Jeff
Flake and Murkowski and Collins and
number three they hope although the
FBI's FBI said they're not going to do
this but what they're hoping is that the
FBI will follow irrelevant trails in two
unconnected but embarrassing matters
thus further destroying Cavanaugh's
reputations are their hope they know
that the FBI is not going to come up
with evidence about this allegation they
know that okay just what you need to say
everybody who knows anything and no
matter where they stand on whether or
not this investigation should happen
they all know every rational person
knows that the FBI will not find out
anything about this actual thing itself
what they're hoping though is that
they'll find other information that's
got nothing to do with sexual assault
perhaps but will still be embarrassing
for Brett Kavanaugh and it goes without
saying as I said already Democrats will
demand another delay after this
concludes they'll call the UH
investigation unfair no matter how its
conducted no matter how
it concludes short of the FBI coming out
and saying yes Brett Kavanaugh was a
serial rapist and he's going to prison
okay
short of that they're going to be
unhappy they're not gonna be happy with
a week they wouldn't be happy with two
weeks they're not happy with anything
okay
so so we understand this so I say it
again no matter what no matter what they
will not be swayed no matter what the
people who are against Kavanagh will
remain against him no matter what
Christine Ford could retract her
allegation and it wouldn't sway them it
really wouldn't okay one other thing one
other thing I want to mention here
somewhat connected you're gonna hear a
lot this week and we've already heard
quite a bit in the last few days but
you're gonna hear even more about Brett
Kavanaugh supposedly lying under oath
okay in front of the Senate I know that
the Liberal Liberals are hoping that
this is proven by the FBI investigation
but it can't be it won't be either way
we'll get to that in a minute but but
the claim is what what what what we're
hearing and I think we're gonna hear
more about this is the this is the theme
that's gonna be hammered on quite a bit
is that is that we know that Cavanaugh
did lie at least a couple of times about
a couple of seemingly silly things but
he lied that's the claim because one he
was um he was asked about the Devil's
Triangle which was something that he
wrote in his yearbook about Devil's
Triangle he's asked what does that refer
to he said it was a drinking game - he
was asked about goofing okay again that
was in his yearbook and he said that
it's flatulence right the problem is
that at least today those terms don't
mean those things okay it's not what
those turns mean today Devil's Triangle
is a sex act and
roofing is where you consume alcohol
through your rectum okay don't try it at
home kids
or at work actually don't try it
anywhere in general so especially at
work honestly I mean you really just
shouldn't try so we're told that that he
lied under oath and so even if he didn't
assault anyone he should be disqualified
just on that basis alum that's that's
the argument so should he be should it
seem is he now disqualified anyway
because of the things that he said in
front of the Senate I say no
for three reasons okay number one these
are slang words and terms and it's
possible that they meant something else
back then I mean slang changes over time
it's it's possible that his group of
friends had developed a different
meaning for those terms or that the
terms have just developed I mean it's
possible that Devil's Triangle was a
drinking game back then and then later
became associated with a sex act I mean
who knows you know and whether or not
that was a commonly used expression the
fact is I mean my friends and I when I
was when I was a kid I wasn't when I was
teenager we had all kinds of slang words
and terms and phrases we practically our
own language and and I think that's
pretty common especially among guys so
you know you got to keep that in mind
number two even if those terms really
don't and didn't even back then mean
what Cavanaugh said you still can't
prove he lied you could never prove that
because it could be that he just forgot
you could have misremembered Kristine
Ford forgot a lot of things okay she
forgot many many important details but
she still felt okay coming out with
these allegations against against
someone even though she had no you know
she didn't know even the basic details
about when and where it happened
so she forgot that I think Cavanaugh is
entitled to forget like what's dumb
slang terms meant 35 years ago
so regardless worst case you would just
say well maybe he forgot number three
all right let's say for the sake of
discussion that Cavanaugh did remember
what those terms meant and they didn't
mean what he said and so he did lie
let's just say okay again that can never
be proven we can never know that it was
a lie so so it's kind of irrelevant
anyway because we can't know but let's
just say for now that it was a lie okay
let's just follow that thread it was a
lie under oath for the sake of
discussion a lie in front of a
senatorial committee under oath would
that disqualify him and I would still
say even then no and I know we can all
say was a lie under oath was perjury oh
my goodness it doesn't matter what it
was about it's a lie under oath that's
it really it does it are you sure about
are you sure that it really doesn't
matter what it was about are you sure I
know it sounds very noble for you to say
that and you sound very honest he said
well the words I would never launder
oath about anything what a dummy to say
if anyone who would do that they're a
pathological liar
terrible sounds very noble of you I
don't believe you though that's the
thing I don't believe you
or I don't think that you've thought
this all the way through now it is look
it's wrong to lie it's it's wrong to lie
under oath it's wrong to lie in any
situation it's it's wrong to lie on a
boat with a goat in a house with a mouse
you know and anywhere and if he did lie
about those things then he should repent
of it before God but I am not
comfortable setting a precedent where a
Supreme Court nominee can be
disqualified by that kind of thing
what I mean is these were humiliating
irrelevant deeply personal questions
that were asked in bad faith in order to
paint him as a pervert
and a rapist okay so if he lied if then
he lied out of humiliation embarrassment
and probably a certain contempt for the
questions themselves and the people who
are asking them and probably a certain
feeling that while these people don't
have any right to this information in
the first place does that make it okay
morally objectively no does it make it
disqualifying well think very long and
hard before you call it disqualifying
just just just think about it because if
that's disqualifying then guess what
this is the game from here on out are
you prepared for that you're very noble
and honest position this is where it
brings us are you prepared for that it
means that from here on out Democrats
will try to disqualify every Supreme
Court nominee by traipsing them in front
of the Senate and asking them the most
personal embarrassing irrelevant
bad-faith questions possible and if they
can back the person into a corner where
they state the truth out of sheer
humiliation then they're disqualified
and so suddenly the litmus test for the
highest court in the land becomes a
person's ability to endure shame and
mockery from the vultures in the
Democrat Party but why should that be
the litmus test why is that all this I
know you might say one of the litmus
tests is honesty well look we already
know that nobody is 100% honest everyone
tells lies even Supreme Court justices
everybody does sometimes okay it's bad
everyone does it right so it's not as
though we're under any illusion that
we're gonna find someone who's a hundred
percent totally honest all the time what
we want to find out about apparently if
this becomes a litmus test it's will
they be 100 percent honest in that
situation with the most personal
irrelevant embarrassing details asked by
people in bad faith for the purpose of
painting them as something that they are
not will they be totally honest in that
situation and I say why should that be
the litmus test for the Supreme Court
because it's got nothing to do with what
the Supreme Court does nothing at all I
mean this whole circuit
act has nothing to do with the Supreme
Court they're gonna sit down and they're
gonna decide late legal okay they're
gonna look at cases and apply it to the
Constitution and so if we've got someone
doing that who you know draws a certain
line and says look I'm just not gonna
you know I'm not gonna tell you this
kind of information about you know my
personal life well what does that have
to do cares what does that have to do
with the with whether or not they can
assess the constitutionality of a
situation so again I mean let's just
let's just let's just follow this thread
okay so so what if the next nominee you
know you've got the next nominee up
there and they're asked under they're
under oath right and and so they say you
know they're asked a judge we heard that
you have a flatulence problem is that
true judge is it is it true that you
peed the bed until 12th grade ma'am is
it true that you lost your virginity at
the age of 14 is that true is that true
it is is it true that you lost your
virginity at age of 14 but you lied to
your husband you said you were a virgin
when you married is that is that true
ma'am did you suffer postpartum
depression after your last child there
are reports there's a severe postpartum
depression is that true ma'am we need an
answer you're under oath ma'am sir sir
there are reports that your wife caught
you watching internet pornography back
in 2007 is that is that true sir you're
under oath sir we need an answer to that
question ma'am are these reports correct
that you have irritable bowel syndrome
and you have to defecate five times a
day ma'am you are under oath we need an
answer
ma'am the country deserves to know sir
is it true that you had a homosexual
experience in college there are several
reports of this sort we need we're going
to need an answer to that sir your
homosexual experience did it happen
ma'am is it true that you have a body
odor problem ma'am is it true that you
once went three days without brushing
your teeth that's the reports that we're
hearing ma'am you are under oath I
remind you again answer the question and
on and on and on okay are we are we
prepared to say that
only people the only people qualified
for the Supreme Court are those who are
willing to be interrogated with
questions like those and who will answer
them honestly even though they have
absolutely no bearing on anything and
they're only being asked in order to
paint a negative portrait of the nominee
and to humiliate them are we prepared
for that so all these people saying well
perjuries perjury all perjury is the
same really is it
I mean is it honestly though is it all
exactly the same look it's too bad if
Cavanaugh lied about poofing okay under
oath when he was asked about it by
people who are trying to paint him as a
rapist
I think his better course would then
just to refuse to answer those questions
completely that would have been you know
if it was alive I mean the better course
would have been to not answer them both
the more honest course but also just the
more I think just the more effective
course is just to say I'm not gonna
answer those stupid ridiculous questions
and you should be ashamed and
embarrassed for asking me them you
vulture it's what he should have said
but if backed into a corner he said you
know flatulence I mean you know it's
like not the same thing but kind of
related then you know that's that's very
naughty of him that's he should
apologize to God but disqualifying come
on I mean seriously
a guy who who has by by all accounts is
a very competent and honest judge in
that situation if he was not totally
honest about poofing in front of the
Senate he's disqualified I really want
you to think about that if that's the
position that you're taking I really
want you to think if that if that really
makes sense to you okay come on I just
I'm not saying we become moral
relativists or we become ends justify
the means kinds of people but we got it
like we can't the Democrats and liberals
are playing a game and we have to stop
so willingly going along with it right I
mean what we'll see what the FBI turns
up maybe they will follow the roofing
trail to its conclusion and and then you
know and that's what this will become
all about who knows all right have a
great day everybody to talk to you
tomorrow
Godspeed